Let's continue.
Cool. So we are...
...polished.
That was a trade.
And a loss.
So we're still going 1% current balance.
Probably should have kept everything to a nature balance to be honest with you.
I would have made the date a lot easier to read.
Because all of a sudden when you start getting...
...you know, almost 73% of profit on your risk is not the same.
But then it's still 1% risk of the account that you have.
It's a difficult one.
But it's not that big of a deal.
So we know we lose this.
That's all good.
So we're still going to be honest with you.
We're still going to be honest with you.
I'm not actually even sure if there's news as to...
...we have ISM manufacturing.
And there we go.
Obviously we're not going to get a trade-off after that.
Probably not going to get one in New York either.
Price would have to come back up to a reasonable point of interest.
Okay.
It was probably an entry.
Again, really just the buy-to-sells.
What's the rest reward on that?
It looks like 1 to 2.5, 1 to 3.
We're still going to be honest with you.
I'm not going to get a good car or something.
It's not until November.
Honestly, for this trade here, I guess this value got.
I'll at least be pulling some of my rest off because it could be a break even.
Yeah, for sure.
Okay, where's 5R?
Friday the 9th of August.
No news apparently.
Fair enough.
I'm not going to get a good car or something.
Sometimes you just have to go the entire way to figure it out.
I put my stops above here, arguably break even, pull out, shift, pull work,
mitigation, continuation, but probably says break even.
Fair.
I'm not going to get a good car or something.
It's a crazy distance.
Tag straight away.
Probably move our cut half of our risk off.
I don't see why price would need to trade higher from this level.
This is maybe an obsession that you can look at scale in.
Again, what I care about here is liquidity.
That's the intraday bias.
We're going to obviously end goal.
It's going to be you.
I don't need like one to five, one to six, one to seven.
One to seven again.
You can leave a portion position to run to the 15-hour move.
Maybe we can even scale in here.
Now we've cut risk.
Maybe we even scale in.
It's still only a 1% loss.
We have 1% risk open still.
If we have the conviction in the price movement, then why not?
Let's think we can get to break even there as well.
Let's stop loss.
Don't see what we can't get to break even here.
You can leave that when I break even for now.
Okay, because 5R for you is here.
Nice.
50% of our first position.
Let's hit our second level as well.
Just scale in our way out.
We tried.
What is that?
PPI.
Oh, we tried.
This is the first position.
This is the Frank's sweep.
Frank's sweep continues.
No Frank's sweep reversal.
It's a strong point of interest.
Then 2-3 AM is a really good window, if I'm not mistaken, and then second
execution.
3-4 AM is our worst as well.
I have to put this down to discretion.
Technically just scale into a position that's not an actual playbook, so does
that make sense?
Okay.
Oh, wait, so it shouldn't actually follow a playbook.
Although, no, it should.
Are we going to go for these highs?
We did run for a decent amount of liquidity.
Make sure we're still recording.
That's a sweep.
That's a continuation.
Okay, obviously we're bullish.
Yeah, the M1 is technically bearish.
I don't really know how to categorize this price section.
So, as I say, 15s, what do we have today?
Retail sales.
Maybe retail sales will shake things up because I don't know how to categorize
that short,
long, bearish, bullish.
Damn, that's a crazy retail sales.
I don't really understand the price section.
I mean, technically we have to be bullish because we don't break anything to be
bearish.
But it's just, yeah, not a great price section.
Well, now we're very likely to be bearish.
Yeah, and I would bearish.
Friday 16th.
We have build impalments.
Right.
Hold up for a minute.
That's what I was saying.
I mean, technically the M1 is bearish.
We could go to internal, but it would still be "discretion."
Right, so.
Yeah.
Hmm.
It's all efficient pricing.
M15 areas, unmegated.
Look at our risk, at least.
Again, another instance of cut and risk, favorable.
Honestly, we don't win the trade, but it's good management.
We're going to be able to do that.
Session over.
Okay.
Good luck trading that.
All right.
Talk about technical.
Again, guys, like kind of some more details is
try and test and understand, you know, when you may want to hold positions
longer and stuff like that as well.
Just test, test, test, test.
That's a mitigation.
Let's see how we react.
And we get taken out.
And it's good management.
Again, we reduce, you know, probably more than 50% of our risk.
I have no idea if we're profitable for this month.
Let's do it to 3am, right?
Technically, we can trade long from here, but the reality is, is I don't think
price comes back.
I don't know.
Technically, it does.
Okay.
Not a huge fan of the setup in general, to be honest.
Like, does this a ridiculous need for higher prices?
I just don't understand.
Maybe we manage it dynamically.
I'll manage it how I would manage it in real time.
And if that comes off of the discretion, then I'll have to put it as discretion
.
Because, I mean, it is technically a setup.
The problem is, it's different.
There's been a couple of setups where it's like, it's being a setup.
The setup is really dodgy.
At least this is, like, actually just clean sweep of Asia, shift, pullback.
And requirement is a continuation.
I'm not going to get to breakeven either, honestly.
It's the 20th.
There's still no news, but honestly, like, even though technically when it gets
a breakeven
right now, I'm at least going to reduce half my risk.
London session, New York, so open in as well.
That's the area that I expect to be respected.
I'll then move my risk up to here.
Now I'll move to breakeven.
Again, notice the management there.
And honestly, it doesn't really matter.
Honestly, that's exceptional trade management.
Exceptional trade management.
Something I'm noticing with this specific setup.
Transcending right.
Okay.
Definitely don't want to be trading in New York today, but non-farm NFP, let's
say, 21st.
Non-farm payrolls annual revision.
Debatable.
But that's obviously a change of character.
I'm definitely not holding through New York.
And out.
I'm not holding through New York today.
Just pressure it higher.
That means you've got to respect the accuracy of that type of suite before
reversal.
And then the build-up of liquidity on the buy side as well.
There's no way on earth you could tell me that is accidental and intentional.
Not a chance.
Let's see, London 22nd.
Excuse me, guys.
I'm a little bit tired.
We have H-COB, which is not ideal.
We run that daily high as well, that I've marked out.
I don't want to enter before H-COB.
It's technically an entry, but I'm not going to hold this through H-COB.
Those lows as well, crazy, but time is at 2.30 and one hour.
It's within 30 minutes of news.
There's still no tag.
And the news is about to drop.
Exactly.
H-COB is something you always want to avoid for Europe.
I don't know, it always has that effect.
That's a New York session.
Wait.
There's nothing in this New York session because we're bullish anyway.
Oh, wait, that's not true.
There may be a setup here that we've just missed.
Okay.
Wait, it's the 22nd.
No, no news.
Is there a setup that we missed?
Nope.
There's a swing high in London.
So we're still technically bullish.
New York session is about to stop.
Technically bullish, although, like, just really don't like this liquidity.
It's outside Friday, 23rd.
We have FITPOW at 10.
There's nothing for London.
Is there an entry there?
Probably not.
Possibly.
I mean, technically, but I also would have been stopped at a break even.
But I guess I should still take the trade for the day.
So it's going to end up being a break even.
In fact, what does the M5 look like?
Yeah, I would use the invite for you up as well.
Not a huge front of the price action, to be honest, but...
Just again, just for the purpose of collecting the data.
That's where I'll immediately be at break here.
Plan is it more?
Yeah, I'll break here.
Oh, my God.
I don't know, it's really weird.
In turn, I guess it's technically kind of a trend.
Premium discount, yes, technically, no news.
See what New York has to offer?
I'm doing solid management.
Maybe.
It's tempting me.
I'll be honest, it's like a potential that I take down the live market.
But potential, I don't know.
There's no potential that I take it, a third-power speech.
I'm not having that much influence that you just speak in the market, just
hundreds of billions of dollars just move.
Interest in life situation.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh, wait.
I have a business climate.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
M1's ranging from up here to down here.
Still ranging.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Just skipped to an entirely new New Yorker.
The M1, no, it's still not gonna be a trade.
The M1 hides up there somewhere.
The M1's bullish.
So I can't skip to tomorrow, at least.
Well, we are obviously bearish.
Probably not gonna get a trade though.
Still bearish.
29th.
It could be a trade, do we have any news?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah, we do.
Inflation rate, GDP.
Cold with bearish, looking for shorts.
Could be looking at short in here.
If the structure is on point, which it does not look like it is.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Maybe it's three candles.
Yeah.
Telegram is, buy to sell.
M15 is the same.
Basically five hours of lows.
And no bueno.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah, that'd be messed up.
The question is.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
No, we have a break here.
Two candles.
Maybe I'll final set up for the months.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And yeah, core producer price index.
I'm never gonna trade that.
What's that done?
Okay, that is July and August in that sitting.
So when rate dropped, but, but, but, but, although the win rate may have
dropped.
The, the average, the average loss, I think was better in that, in that sitting
.
Because win rate is also just one thing like you can have.
Like we already seen with 16% win rate still profitable.
It's like you could.
Excuse me, guys.
You could lose trades, but the loss on the trade is like 0.25%.
0.2%.
And five losses equate to one hour.
And so you take five losses with good management and one winner.
And you're still net profitable by 4X.
Right with the 20% win rate.
That's the importance of obviously trade management.
So this is what I mean, like, don't be fooled by people who show impressive win
rates.
Because win rate is useless.
Like Einstein has the equation E equals MC squared, right?
Now if I just sat here and talked about E, like it's useless.
It's the entire equation that, that gives the E any sense of value, meaning or
usefulness.
And so it's the same thing with win rate.
Win rate is useless.
Like you might have a 70% win rate, but your average win to loss is
significantly lower.
You might have a 0.5 average win to loss ratio.
Right.
So don't be fooled.
Like we're here with a three, the real numbers this profit factor.
You can have a guy with a 80% win rate, holy grail strategy.
Billing a win streak.
Haven't lost a trade in six weeks.
And he's got a 1.1 profit factor.
Like just don't be fooled.
Might go on a six week win streak, but one trade wipes your entire gains out.
Like what was, what was the point of wasting all the time?
So make sure you optimize them for results.
Zella score is still healthy.
That's a really healthy score.
Obviously the win rate is lower, but the win rate is something that I believe I
can bring
up by analyzing the data.
For example, as of right now, every trade is technically profitable.
I would like, I would need to see the, the in depth data of each system itself.
I'll do it.
I won't waste time doing it now.
Like, for example, London sweep Asia, right?
It's profitable.
It's our most traded, but it has a 28% win rate.
I'm pretty sure that I could, by the end of this testing, I could look at all
these trades
that I can find in common, common character patterns that I can then take as
principles
and then retest and get new info.
This is also how you try to find your A plus set ups, right?
This set up has a 1.67 profit factor.
It's the same playbook.
It's the same playbook, but that set up has a 1.6% profit factor.
It's only had two trades.
Let's look at this, for example.
This is the highest profit factor.
Look at profit factor of 10.
Right.
This is an A plus set up.
Now, obviously, three trades isn't enough.
Three trades isn't enough data.
And three trades in a couple months is also another thing.
This is what I mean.
Like, you'll start to see that's my -- it's not an A plus set up, but it's the
set up that
most commonly occurs and it's profitable.
This is an A plus set up.
This trading set up only shows up and average once a month, right?
Maybe now you start adjusting.
Like, maybe I increase my risk.
Maybe I increase my size on this trade.
It's all in the data.
Don't guess.
Don't trade something because someone else trades it.
Be an independent thinker.
Be an independent trader.